to build up this list item we created a
horizontal linear layout with three
children the first child is an imageview
the second child is a vertical linear
layout composed of two textview stacked
on top of each other the third child is
the same it's a vertical linear layout
composed of the two temperature textview
stacked on top of each other now you
might be wondering why we didn't use a
relative layout because that would give
us less layers of hierarchy well
relative layouts are good if you want to
specify that one view should be to the
right of another or on top of another
view relative lands are also good if you
want a view to be aligned to the parents
left top right or bottom but it's harder
in this case to Center these two text
views within the vertical height
allocated by this image view it's easier
with a linear layout here and here so if
the image was any taller these two text
views would still stay vertically
centered and this is what it looks like
in the device preview within Android
studio I want to point out one thing
about this horizontal linear layout
which has three children the image view
the vertical linear layout and the other
vertical linear layout the second child
actually has a width of 0dp but a weight
of one that means that any horizontal
space that's not taken up by other
children will be distributed among views
that have assigned weights so if we look
at this third child it has a width of
wrap content and a weight of zero if we
gave it a weight of one then it would
stretch out like this basically the icon
is a fixed width and then the remaining
horizontal space is divided among these
two children since they both have a
weight one is distributed equally but if
you look at the wireframes these
temperature views are actually aligned
to the right so all we need is for the
width to be wrapped content and for the
wait to be zero then any remaining
horizontal space will be assigned to
this middle element with a weight of one
and this is the code for the XML layout
we have a linear layout in horizontal
orientation the width is match parent to
match the width of the screen and each
list item has wrapped content on its
height but it does have a minimum height
at least of this attribute list
preferred item height we specify gravity
to be center vertical so that all of his
children are vertically centered within
it we also specify a little bit of
padding inside of it we add an image
view which has wrap content for height
and width and we specify the source as
this placeholder draw
next we have the vertical linear layout
where the width is zero DP and the
weight is one we specify a little bit of
padding between this view and the icon
beside it within the linear layout we
have the date text view as well as the
forecast textview beside that we have
another vertical linear layout with the
high temperature textview in the low
temperature textview and that's it